again welcome to the University church
especially to pair
family and friends visiting this weekend
we wish the heat wrong the heat was on
in July but it's not on now welcome to
Yale you are always welcome here and we
hope that is a little more commodious in
future weeks but a brief warning to
parents if you come up after worship and
coffee hour and shake my hand and I
don't immediately recognize your son or
daughter it's not because they haven't
been in church every week it's just my
bad memory so don't worry seems every
year that family weekend falls on a
Sunday where we're assigned awful
scriptures I hate to ever say the
scripture is awful but the way they fall
together and sometimes seemed really
tough a couple years ago it was Jesus
telling the young man sell all you have
and give to the poor something parents
who hope their children will support
them in retirement really don't want to
hear I think last year it was Jesus
saying in Luke 14 whoever does not hate
their mother and father cannot become my
disciple I'm serious it was true and
today our scriptures are even tougher in
a way as you just heard they are hard
prophetic texts first the prophet Micah
who's sort of our patron profit here at
you see why railing against the other
prophets who are saying that
everything's fine and God is on our side
and then Jesus condemning some of the
Pharisees as hypocrites imposing rules
on others they won't follow themselves
why can't we just get the prodigal son
or the Good Shepherd for family weekend
one year no we get my god and can
condemnation of the Pharisees but even
this strange juxtaposition of church and
Yale calendars has a message I believe
and it's a message for the family
members and friends who are here
students you can listen in but it's
really a conversation with me in the
parents
don't be surprised that if you teach
your children the faith in God that one
day you might wake up with a prophet in
your house it might be last for a week
it might last for a month in my last for
a year or haven't helped you it might
last for a lifetime profits are
unnatural though thankfully rare
consequence of teaching a faith in a God
of justice and I think you may be in
special trouble because this generation
of students was raised on Martin Luther
King and Rosa Parks and Nelson Mandela
but no thoughtful parent I think wishes
for a profit profits are if micah is any
indication lonely a little obsessed and
pretty much unlovable they tend to be
extremists profits do not have happy
family lives and who wishes that for
their child our Mecca reading today
leaves off the first few chapter verses
of chapter 3 but I think we might need
to hear them just to get an indication
of what might happen in your home if
this prophet suddenly appears the child
the beloved child he once knew returns
as a prophet Micah rights listen you
heads of Jacob and your rulers of the
house of Israel should you not know
justice you who hate the good and love
the evil who tear the skin off my people
and the flesh off their bones who eat
the flesh of my people who Flay their
skin off them break their bones and
pieces chop them up like meat in a
kettle like flesh in a cauldron as you
might guess prophets don't interview
well
they are not good dinner guests Micah
was writing in the 8th century BC around
the same time the legend is that Romulus
and Remus founded the city of Rome
around the same time Homer was
supposedly writing the Iliad and the
Odyssey at that time the Assyrians were
the imperial power of the Middle East
and it already conquered Damascus and
then Samaria the capital the neighboring
Kingdom and the Assyrian armies were
circling around Judah and Jerusalem
where Micah preached and my co was
desperate but not just about politics he
felt that the Covenant society that God
had created was breaking down that the
tribal ancestral lands so critical to
traditional Israelite society were being
bought up by rich elites in the cities
refugees were flooding in from the north
the rich and powerful he said we're
cheating the poor and if we take his
metaphor chopping them up and eating
them the problem with faith is that once
you have it it has an awful propensity
to take over your whole life leaving not
nearly enough room for home decorating
or leisure travel and when you have
faith you start looking out of the world
and noticing things other people don't
see the injustice you see gets under
your skin you want to accept the easy
explanations for it you want to believe
that it when people tell you there's
nothing you can do about it just live
with it but the God you taught your
children about is a just God you read
your children those passages the widow
with their two small coins the
blessedness of the poor salvation by
giving a cup of cool water the
separation of the sheeps and the goats
you know the stories but you never
imagined that your son or daughter would
take them literally you but choose
nonetheless you taught them and you
didn't warn them you didn't say now this
is a fairy tale
this is like Goldilocks and the three
bears exposure to the god of the
scriptures is terrible preparation for a
happy and easy life this is a God who
regularly seems to choose the weakest
and the least likely to be his agent
this God's prophets are hounded through
their lives this is a God after all
whose son did not get a trust fund an
expensive boarding school he got a
manger in a carpenter's shop and a
wandering teachers poverty and finally a
quick and brutal death what were you
thinking when you're told your children
these stories I really wonder if you're
fit parents how could you and I wonder
about your self-preservation instincts
as well after all what do Micah and
Jesus tell us today that God hates
hypocrisy and to what do all adolescents
develop an exquisite sensitivity you
know as parents hypocrisy you're just
asking for a minut examination of every
single one of your actions throughout
your life and yet you're surprised when
you hear your children say but you said
and you're shocked when you thought you
were picking up sarah or josh at the
airport and suddenly the prophet Micah
walks into your house and starts
dissecting how your lifestyle is
crushing the poor in the developing
world you should have known better but
all humor aside what do we do with our
children or ourselves when they start
seeing the world not as we hoped it
would be but as it is when the hypocrisy
around us becomes unbearable when
economics seem to trump even God's
justice what do we do when we look out
at the world and the deep injustice of
it all begins to push our thinking to
extremes when we can't help but feel
that our society has gone deeply wrong
when we can no longer pretend not to see
the despair the hung
the anger the extremism and the deep
injustice what do we do we become
prophets but we do so with mica and
Jesus ringing in our ears because what
is the greatest danger for a profit same
danger hypocrisy one commentator I read
said that we hear these texts for today
not to get us excited about condemning
the false prophets of our time because
Fox News and MSNBC do plenty of that
rather we hear these texts as warnings
to us as Christians that even when we're
on the side of justice we must take care
not to become hypocrites ourselves I
don't know if you've heard this but
passion is a buzzword in higher
education these days though thankfully i
think it's beginning to fade out how
often did I hear administrators say to
students find your passion and pursue it
but passion for its own sake or for the
sake of the feelings it gives us is a
truly dangerous thing but of course you
can't tell a prophet bad what does micah
say these prophets are silenced but as
for me I am filled with power with the
Spirit of the Lord with justice and
might to declare to Jacob his
transgression into Israel his sin so how
can we possibly balance prophetic power
with humility how do we somehow connect
passion with integrity when I feel about
a prophetic behavior coming on which
happens every now and then I ask myself
is this about God and the poor or is
this about me am I likely to make
matters better or worse by my
involvement to actually know any of the
people whose interests I'm supposedly
defending would it make more sense for
them to be talking than me and most of
all have I worked out my own
choose enough that I won't get in the
way or project my personal problems on
to my actions is this issue this
injustice bigger than my involvement in
it so when a student comes to me on fire
for justice blissfully unaware of the
personal costs ahead probably headed for
disappointment or disillusionment part
of me wants to warn them off as I know
you do study accounting please get a
nice job have a nice life but what if my
student or your child truly is called by
God scary prospect who will by sheer
personal force and probably
self-destruction truly open people's
eyes and change the world I think we'll
stand aside like Mary and Joseph did
unsure what to do with this very strange
child but in the end we have no one to
blame but ourselves we taught them that
the one true God is the one who will
cast the mighty from their thrones and
lift up the lowly a god who's more
concerned for the least of our brothers
and sisters than for hedge fund managers
pop stars professional athletes or even
named professors a God who loves with an
undying passion the lost the prisoners
the addicts the prostitutes and the tax
collectors a God who in the end and
probably against our wishes raises up
profits from our midst amen